Shack
has an important message for everybody
especially for people in the media and
that is Don't Call Him a celebrity I
really love this story I meant to get to
it a couple days ago glad we can get to
it now Shaq is very very famous
figure in sports in media in commentary
and Shaq just told People magazine that
he doesn't want to be a celebrity
because celebrities are rude to people
and obnoxious said I denounced myself
for being a celebrity 30 years ago
because a lot of celebrities are a-holes
I don't want to be in that category I'd
rather demote myself to just being a
regular person before you call me a
celebrity and put me in the category of
those jerk offs I don't I think I can
say that on the air right so that seems
relatively wholesome by our modern
cultural standards I don't like to work
with celebrities because celebrities are
crazy so I just like to work with people
and he says celebrities are crazy they
really are don't call me that anymore
these people are out of their freaking
mind with how they treat people what
they do what they say that's never been
me I never want to be looked at like
that so some people are going to look at
this and say oh that's just false
humility from Shaq
you're obviously a celebrity you're
super rich you're super famous he's not
saying that he's not rich and famous
he's just rightly observing that
celebrities often have all sorts of
problems and look ridiculous
so when he says oh don't call me a
celebrity I just want to be a regular
person he's not even saying that
for you or for me
or for anybody else he's he's calling
for that as a matter of
self-preservation and you see this
throughout the ages people get really
dazzled by celebrity
people can become star struck but think
about celebrities of Ages past celebrity
fades in a second people who were super
famous admired all we could talk about
even five ten years ago
they're forgotten and then they what
they become washed up they become a
punch line and very often they're
self-obsessed very often they are rude
to people very often they are crazy it's
not even totally their fault celebrity
is a weird thing if you if you've ever
known a famous person and having lived
in LA and being around politics I've met
a disproportionate number of famous
people they can go crazy it's a very
strange thing to have everybody admire
you at once and come up to you and
recognize you and treat you well and
pick up the tab that if you don't
protect yourself that can really
that can really warp your mind and your
perception and some of the famous people
I've known have protected themselves
better than others against it so what
Shaq is saying is no
ultimately
celebrity doesn't mean anything it's an
illusion
and it's a deception don't
fall for it and that's so true and it's
it's a lesson for all of us in this age
because we're in an age where everybody
can have their 15 minutes of fame
because anybody can go viral on tick
tock
and so it's a it's a lesson for us we've
democratized celebrity now and
the
success of this world can be very
damaging to people's Souls it's a great
bit of self-help from Shaq it's not
false modesty I think that is looking at
the world with a Steely eye because if
you or I have met a few famous people
think about all the famous ones Shack
knows the man knows of what he speaks
speaking of idol worship
did you know paganism is coming back
good piece here in commentary magazine
on the return of paganism a spiritual
crisis afflicting contemporary America
has ancient and enduring roots and so
does the Cure I actually haven't had
time even to go through the entire piece
but it makes it a really
important point
which is paganism is coming back
the paganism that you don't really
notice where you just
start to worship money and you start to
worship sex and you start to worship all
the created things of this world
celebrity and you don't really notice it
also overt paganism is coming back also
steeped in Tradition kind of paganism
nature worship polytheism that is coming
back in a pretty conscious way as well
and the reason for this is that we've
kicked Christianity out of the Public
Square
and this has happened not only because
of the faithlessness of of the members
in the church but also because leftist
activists have booted it out using the
law using political activism from the
Public Square so when you don't let kids
learning the Bible in schools when you
don't let people pray in schools when
you instead when you replace the Bible
with pornography in schools as we're
seeing today that's going to change
people's formation so
everybody's got to serve somebody
but
there's a priest who who said that when
he was in seminary he was told by one of
his teachers that if he should ever
leave Christianity he should become a
pagan
and this wasn't just a cheeky line the
reason for this is paganism is at the
very least tied to Nature
and so I'm not advocating that anyone
become a pagan but it's got some
connection to reality and I think a part
of the rise of paganism conscious and
unconscious is that we are living in a
virtual world that is now imbued with
that is that has been pervaded with this
this silly ideology that that tells us
the things that we know to be true are
not true that a man is not really a man
he's a woman that a baby he's not really
a baby it's a clump of cells or whatever
we're living in a world where these
ideologies can succeed because we're so
divorced from the real world we live in
these little cubes and we insulate
ourselves from nature and we even
insulate ourselves from our own bodies
we can alienate ourselves from our own
bodies through virtual reality through
social media through the internet
and so there is an appeal I think to get
back to something tangible Something Old
Something sturdy now ultimately that
won't be enduring because even the
physical world even nature will pass
away it seems a lot sturdier than the
fantasy virtual world that many people
are living in now but even this created
world will pass away so when you are
looking for something when when you're
trying to fill the god-shaped hole in
your heart when you recognize that
everybody's got to serve somebody
you've got to go past that follow that
desire that has led you to the kind of
new paganism that's cropping up
everywhere but take it to the place that
is enduring take it to the source that
is outside of this finite world uh take
it take it to he who will not to him who
will not pass away the United Nations
has has made a troubling statement
this is the international Commission of
jurists with an assist from U.N AIDS and
the office of the United Nations High
Commissioner for human rights if said
quote
sexual conduct involving persons below
the domestically prescribed minimum age
of consent to sex
may be consensual in fact if not in law
now to translate all of that
gobbledygook what they're saying is
maybe it's okay to have sex with kids
that's what that means this is from a
report titled the eight March principles
for a human rights-based approach to
criminal law pro-scribing conduct
associated with sex reproduction drug
use HIV homelessness and poverty I think
of Oren McIntyre the commentator who's
come on this show before
who has a meme that has gone viral and
it's a meme speaking of The Simpsons of
a bus driver on the symptom Simpson's
saying don't make me tap the sign and
the sign is just a tweet from Mr
McIntyre saying it's not complicated
they just want to diddle kids and I I
don't think that that's all of what the
sexual Revolution is about but going way
way back going back to the 1960s going
back to those weird essays by Bernie
Sanders in the Vermont Freeman in which
he's writing about how awful it is that
we don't sexualize children and going
back to the bizarre sexual Revolutions
of even a little before the 1960s even
back to the days of the leftist
intellectual Wilhelm Reich the the idea
of organs as being the the essence of
life and the way to cure poverty and
cancer and war is to just have a lot of
orgasms I'm not making that up the way
that the libs keep constantly trying to
sexualize kids in the schools in the
libraries expose them to drag queens
there's a highly ideological component
about it but also
Mr McIntyre might happen to be right
that clip was very very insightful if I
do say so myself you can get the whole
show right here subscribed Michael Show
YouTube channel see you there
[Music]
foreign